we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a funny thing we
heard about this at one point I think it
was actually people around Trump who
would say things like you know Biden
doesn't have the rally crowds and he
doesn't have the live stream viewers and
he doesn't have the Twitter followers so
how could he possibly have won here's a
guy who called in very angry with me who
has a Twitter based analysis of Biden vs
Trump listen
yes my question to you is how many
followers does Biden have on Twitter
don't know and how many followers does
Trump have I don't know
huh
maybe you should do your research and
see who has more four times as many
followers within a month or two and why
would I care about that and this idiot
that's been in the white house for two
years okay you're the Biggest Loser on
TV right now maybe I am but that doesn't
have anything to do with who won in 2020
and I can argue every one of your points
that you have nothing to back up your
facts with I encourage you to call in
anytime sir you just say things like the
election was not read this that and the
other even though they're proof to the
other side there's no poof there's no
poof nor proof
that it was and that's not a fact so you
cannot bring that that up to the fact
this is the burden of proof thing
they have not demonstrated with any
evidence
that we should distrust the results the
default is because elections have been
happening successfully in the United
States for so long
that when you see that Biden won by
eight million votes unless I have a
reason to doubt that
why would I question it they have to
present the evidence and they have not
because that's your opinion so stop your
[ __ ] opinions because you're a loser
and you're you're killing our country
you're killing our democracy yeah
January 6th rioters aren't the ones
killing democracy Congressman Ralph
Norman texting we need martial law
misspelled by the way they're not
killing democracy me saying
I think Biden really won I'm killing
democracy I think you should just get
off the air right away okay well let's
do that right now it's the end of the
show so I will get off the air uh we've
got a great bonus show for you today
though we're going to talk about
the pushing of anti-Semitism to the
Forefront
in particular by people like Kanye Nick
Fuentes and yes Trump has a has a role
to play in that we're going to talk
about that NASA's Artemis one is back
from the Moon with hopes to get
astronauts back there soon we will talk
about it and will we ever go to Mars or
Nars we will talk about that as well and
yes Sam bankman freed the FTX founder
has been arrested in the Bahamas a
Bahamian arrest has taken place we will
talk about everything that is going on
make sure you're signed up for the bonus
show folks oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
Pat Manson loser that may be Alex but
the bonus show continues and no
defamation suits with a billion dollars
in money awarded against the bonus show
I'm very proud to say that you can sign
up for a membership at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get a discount I'll see you on
the bonus show it's a great thing